[Música]
son los tokens no fungible es solo una
nueva clase de activos digitales que se
almacenan y se manejan dentro de una
cadena de bloques pero a diferencia de
las cripto moneda los nfc por sus siglas
en inglés son activos digitales únicos
insustituibles y tampoco se pueden
intercambiar lo que permite asignarles
una presentación física o también
digital no no fungible a diferencia de
los billetes de las monedas no puede
equipararse con algo exactamente igual
por ello una cadena de bloques es el
ambiente ideal para estos nfc recordemos
que una cadena de bloques es un tipo de
tecnología que permite llevar un
registro de todas las transacciones y la
trazabilidad de quienes la han tenido
han tenido este bien sea fungible como
los bitcoins o no fungible es como los
nfc ahora porque estos nfc se
convirtieron en un negocio millonario
bueno para ello entonces quiero saludar
a nuestro segundo invitado del día eres
oscar olivares artista visual ilustrador
y conferencista venezolano además
acreedor de diversos reconocimientos
nacionales y también internacionales
única no de emprendimiento online 2015 y
premio mara de oro 2017 oscar estamos
con el que es gracia entonces por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 me pregunto qué son los nfc y
cómo entenderlo o fácilmente
bien bueno en primer lugar muchísimas
gracias por la invitación y por el
espacio es realmente un honor mira los
efectos creo que lo ha explicado muy
bien realmente no son un artículo que no
se puede intercambiar por otro y que
está registrado en la blogs en o en una
cadena de bloques esto lo que permite
ver que es totalmente auténtico que es
original de muchas de las críticas que
se les da a los nfc es que son imágenes
que cualquiera puede copiar y descargar
por internet pero yo lo pondría como si
fuese en la entrada a un concierto
imagínate que tú tienes la entrada a un
concierto en digital y llega alguien más
y le toma una foto a la entrada esa
persona que toma una foto la entrada no
puede hacer nada con ella solamente el
dueño de la entrada original puede hacer
uso de la misma y esto es muy importante
porque además de ser una imagen los
gerentes le ofrecen usualmente las
colecciones más interesantes a sus
dueños una serie de beneficios y acceso
a ciertos clubes a ciertos espacios a
ciertas ventajas que solamente tiene el
dueño en el caso por ejemplo de los
gerentes que hemos sacado que ofrece
cursos que ofrece acceso a eventos y
otro tipo de espacio que le dan
muchísimo más interés a estos a manera
de inversión o sea es decir que también
el nfc se ve como tú la quieres y
también tienes servicios si tienes
beneficios por adquirir este nfc como
éste como es este mercado cuál es la
verdadera intención además de esa que
los dijo oscar
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que lo más
interesante es poder tener registro de
que estás adquiriendo un artículo que es
totalmente original te lo digo que llevo
ya más de 10 años trabajando en el mundo
del arte digital y aunque uno como
artista digital le ofreciera la hora en
físico al cliente siempre estaba la idea
de bueno pero yo estoy tengo yo tengo
aquí una impresión pero cuál es el arte
original realmente tú todavía conserva
el archivo
podría imprimir otros entonces el poder
asegurarle al cliente alguna manera que
está adquiriendo una pieza única
exclusiva original siento que sería el
negocio que más más importante y
relevante sin embargo se estaban
utilizando mucho los ene efe test como
justamente barajitas como tokens con
ciertos beneficios como por ejemplo la
entrada o acceso a ciertos clubes que le
están dando un nivel de prestigio muy
importante a ciertas personalidades es
decir ya hoy en día tener un ene efe que
puede darte un estatus mayor que tener
un automóvil que tener una mansión
entonces vemos cómo están cambiando por
completo
el status quo de lo que son las
inversiones a corto mediano e incluso a
largo plazo y cómo ha cambiado entonces
todo este mundo del arte hablemos ahora
oscar del impacto de los nfc en el arte
y también le quiero preguntar que le
dice a los románticos que de cierta
forma no ven y critican esta forma de
arte también como lo son los nfc
bueno yo creo que realmente los artistas
siempre debemos estar a la altura de la
tecnología más importante y más avanzada
en nuestro momento y los ene efe test
son parte de esta tecnología vez más
avanzada en este instante de hecho son
algo que está totalmente en pañales y yo
simplemente diría que el mundo del arte
está migrando a la parte digital bien
como te mencionaba la crítica
fundamental hacia el arte digital hace
unos años era que no podía quizás
venderlo como una pieza única y eso hoy
en día cambia vemos que incluso hay
obras de arte digitales que gracias a
los nfc están teniendo un mayor valor
que obras incluso físicas bien y es
sumamente interesante de acá al futuro
porque obliga a los artistas además a
ofrecer algo distinto a ofrecer ofrecer
algo único porque los efectos son
valiosos por qué tan raros son y en qué
tan diferentes son otro aspecto
importante que yo creo que es un por qué
es relevante destacar es que si habían
vicios en el mercado de arte tradicional
éstos también están migrando el mundo de
los ene efe si bien se habla mucho de
que en los nfc hay mucha especulación
que se están vendiendo artículo que no
se consideran arte pero esto también
pasa en el mundo del arte tradicional
tenemos por ejemplo que una banana bien
pegada con con un tape se subasta por
millones de dólares y pues eso también
está pasando en el mundo de los en ft
gestos realmente lo que veíamos en el
mundo del arte tradicional lo estamos
viendo también ahora en el mundo del
arte digital pero presentando más
oportunidades para todos los artistas
bien como niños de 12 años que nunca
hubiesen tenido una oportunidad en una
galería tradicional están hoy en día
vendiendo su arte por cientos miles o
incluso millones de dólares quería
hablar eso es algo espectacular que
quería hablar sobre todo de eso oscar
del precio más o menos cuando comenzó
usted a realizar este tipo de arte y
verlo como un negocio real a lo mejor
cuánto puede vender una obra cuánto es
lo máximo que usted ha vendido una obra
bien nosotros sacamos la primera
colección de nfc hace mira vamos a
cumplir dos meses un mes si en dos días
apenas bien ha sido algo muy reciente
reciente ha sido una locura totalmente
creamos la primera colección en donde
cada obra estaba alrededor de 230
dólares eran inspiradas en la arepa
venezolana que de hecho es un símbolo en
mi obra muy importante pero lo que nos
llamó la atención es que en sólo tres
minutos ya se habían vendido ocho obras
en estamos hablando de que algo muy loco
bien
la colección se agota por completo en
menos de un día y en 48 horas ya se
estaban vendiendo algunos de los nfc en
reventa a más del doble de su valor bien
algunos llegaron a 511 dólares a un
precio increíble estamos hablando de que
mi obra artística
pasó más o menos 23 años para tener una
revalorización de 100 por ciento y acá
pasó en 48 horas y en switch esto es
algo realmente que a mí me dejó después
desconcertado y hasta el momento el no
frente más valioso que se ha vendido en
esta primera colección llegó a los 700
dólares en la modalidad de subasta que
es la que me parece más interesante
porque es el mismo público el que
establece el precio de la obra y no
solamente el mercado no solamente el
artista no solamente la galería o los
coleccionistas de la misma y oscar de te
metiste saliendo de un poco el tema en
el tema de la arepa la polémica la arepa
venezolana colombiana que bueno ya no
sería otro tema a buscar gracias se nos
acaba el tiempo lamentablemente para
hablar de este apasionante mundo de los
nfc para dónde va el arte y pues qué hay
detrás de todo esto oscar gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 un gran abrazo
desde bogotá
muchas gracias